this is what we're up against this is
how everyone sees him as some kind of
philanthropist out to save the kids at
the valley terry silver
one of you guys named michael it's
michaela whatever i washed my hands at
cobra kite when we lost a tournament i'm
not a sensei anymore
[Music]
as of today i am shutting down miyagido
karate this can't be your plan with
johnny gone it's on me to fix this
one star does a car smell like beer it's
cause there is beer [ __ ]
cobra kai now has more students than
ever before
that means we'll need more senseis i'm
thinking a lot bigger than just the
value
everything was supposed to be better
after the tournament it's only getting
worse
i know how things can start out from
nothing and get bigger and bigger until
all you feel is hate
[Music]
i want you guys to get along we're all
friends now we're not friends we never
will be
silver is dividing and conquering if
this continues all that we have fought
for will not even be memory
i need you to see which of my students
are ready to take the next step
hold on you really won't stop you need
to let me and chosen handle this it's
the only way to make it all in fine
handle it
all we gotta do is get our hands dirty
as you continue down this path nothing
in your life will ever be the same again
[Music]
adult classes are on wednesday we're not
here to take a lesson
we're here to teach you one
[Music]
[Music]
i'm happy to hear that you're doing well
with the others
yeah well i make friends pretty easily
i find that a little kindness goes a
long way
[Music]
you